we are with Google nova after an
important Victory against ashrita
ashrita has been a very difficult player
to gauge because she was winning a lot
of games she was then losing a lot of
which ashrita did you expect to get
today I wasn't sure that's why I was
Lucas worried because sometimes she
comes to surrounding crushes everyone
like she I checked her game she played
so like strong I was like I don't know
which one I'm gonna get but it was like
in between right she didn't collapse
anywhere definitely a streaky player Now
take us through uh the critical moments
and specifically after the opening
because I have a feeling I messed that
up a little bit like G5 F5 it was just
too ambitious after exchanging the
Bishops we don't have anything I was
just hoping that she's gonna exchange
the Queens like that because I saw that
I have E4 so you saw this from afar this
yeah yeah before I played like Queen D7
I saw that idea that Bishop is hanging
all the time so so I just hope for this
but even after that I don't have like I
don't have much but still it's it's not
as easy yeah easy but I'm I need to give
my Pawn back but my position is great so
I thought I'm gonna press here and
actually at this point you had this uh
electrifying move okay that's why I
didn't take uh immediately Knight to F4
did you spot this idea oh night to F4
Knight to F4 yes which wins the game is
it yes because you take take and now you
put the king anywhere no
yes but I I thought about The Rook ji
Sam and I was like wait a second I
should be able to take it but like for
some reason I forgot night F4 back and
then
you ladies were just like shuffling the
pieces I saw the idea of his uh Knight
p392 but I wanted to make it to the uh
like 40 moves so I will get Farthing
hour then after that I thought I'm gonna
like go think about it between 90. I
just knew that if I put my king on G6
then she has always whenever I get this
position Canon G6
share the move
or Knight G4 and after Knight E5 idea no
no not here not in this place at some
point my king was on G6 if I would play
a knight B3 Rook D3 90 bd2 uh Rook D1
and Knight E4 when night her night was
night on G5 and then there's some 95
ideas Knight E5 is a check so I couldn't
uh like go to that line with my king on
G6 and I couldn't go with my King on
East G7 because so he tried to hide the
King on f8 for example yeah if I got can
you go yes a little bit forward
yeah move forward here no instead of
Knight C3
if
if I had my king on jisan for example
she could play Knight F5 check that's
why I was just shuffling and trying to
figure out where to put the king and
basically I just waited for 14 minutes
right and did you see this move Knight
to F2 from afar yeah sure so you were
playing it's beautiful I was like that's
very nice very nice I saw that she
played Knight C3 I thought oh it's
losing then I spotted a free idea but
after F3 I saw Knight F2 which is so
beautiful I'm like I'm gonna go and
after that you convert it nicely
congratulations uh beg him a big victory
for you guys any questions not at all
but just to let you know begum your
coach was very proud of you he was
taking a great deal of credit on your
success
I did not say
[Laughter]
exactly as you should uh crazy things
are happening Anna zatonski